whether animated on film or on TV
Gotham's resident murdering maniac the
Joker is always memorable for every
actor who's given his unnerving cackle
to the Joker there are plenty of notable
actors who just narrowly missed the part
here are some actors who almost played
the Joker Jose Ferrer now you might not
be familiar with Jose Perez acting
resume but the Academy Award winner was
a big deal when producers were casting
the original 1966 Batman TV series
according to producer William Dozier's
original production notes Ferrer was
reportedly up for the role of the Joker
but the actor had scheduling issues we
also tried one other for the Joker and
I'm glad we didn't get him because I
think says our Romero is just
magnificent Cesar Romero eventually
edged Ferrer out even though Romero
refused to shave his trademark mustache
despite Ferrer missing the pot his son
Miguel went on to voice a slew of famous
DC Comics characters including Martian
Manhunter whether wizard and Aquaman
surface-dwellers they're about to cause
the death of millions I have to stop
them Frank Sinatra Adam West's campy
Batman attracted some huge Hollywood
stars is important villains including
Eartha Kitt burgess Meredith and Frank
Gorshin according to Burt Ward's memoir
Boy Wonder my life in tights Frank
Sinatra wanted in on the joke action but
arrived after Cesar Romero had already
signed on upsetting the hopeful Sinatra
there are to be cloud while a crooning
Joker certainly would have made the
clowns elaborate cruelties even weirder
Sinatra posthumously scored his Joker
connection in Rock Steady's Batman
Arkham Knight game where his rendition
of I've got you under my skin plays a
vital role in a Joker related scene use
your mentality Tim Curry no stranger to
playing monsters and creepy clowns Jim
Carrey missed out on the role of the
Joker in two separate productions curry
was among many familiar actors who were
on Tim Burton's shortlist for the iconic
1989 Batman but the eternally creepy
Jack Nicholson ultimately won the role
curry then went on to record multiple
episodes of Batman the Animated Series
as the Joker before being replaced by
Mark Hamill reportedly curries Joker was
a bit too terrifying for the kiddy
demographic and it also strained Curry's
voice he did however lend his laugh - a
robot clown later in the series
close enough Robin Williams one of the
greatest Batman tragedies is the fact
that Robin Williams never had a chance
to play the Joker as a true comic nerd
Williams revealed in a 2010 interview
with Empire magazine that he was
thrilled when he was offered the
villainous role in Burton's Batman after
Nicholson first declined the part until
Nicholson changed his mind the two
seemed to remain cordial however I won
my Academy Award he was there he won
this was his third Academy Award we're
standing backstage cuz they're just but
to take you to the press conference and
he goes you know Robbo now I have one
for every decade
and Williams had a second chance at the
franchise as the Riddler in Batman
Forever
but again the role was yanked out from
under him in favor of Jim Carrey
according to a 2006 IGN interview
Williams also tried to get into
Christopher Nolan's trilogy but was
passed over for Heath Ledger no actor
had ever wanted it so badly
John Lithgow also on the shortlist to
play Tim Burton's Joker
John Lithgow reportedly declined the
role stating that the character didn't
seem appropriate for his particular set
of skills
[Music]
many years later Lisco would play an
incredible viciously memorable serial
killer on Dexter proving that the depths
of his depiction of evil would have been
excellent against Michael Keaton's
Batman instead Lithgow wasted his time
in 1989 on a made-for-tv movie Willem
Dafoe when you kind of look like the
Joker before you even sit in the makeup
chair you're an easy casting decision
Willem Dafoe was another actor who was
briefly considered for the 1989 film
role simply because he looked the part
naturally he later landed the role of
the Green Goblin in 2002 spider-man
another cackling supervillain who is
pretty much Marvel's answer to the Joker
NER Sam Rockwell peeked through Sam
Rockwell's acting history and you'll see
that he can do just about anything he's
rarely failed a role even as the
nameless Punk ringleader in Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles Rockwell was
considered by Christopher Nolan for the
Dark Knight but producers ultimately
went with Heath Ledger instead leaving
this caliber of performance behind oh my
holy crap surveillance doh
I hate those Adrien Brody another Dark
Knight contender Adrien Brody has
publicly expressed an interest in
playing the Joker
according to movie pilot com rumors
arose regarding Brody making a joke a
cameo in Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice but Jared Leto ultimately took
over in the role in DC's extended
universe Brody stated at Kent in 2014
that no one ever approaches him for
comic book roles but there's truly no
better role to fill with completely
offbeat casting Ryan Gosling according
to the rap suicide squads director David
Ayer was aiming for Ryan Gosling to play
the Clown Prince of Crime but got Jared
Leto instead goslings pretty boy Joker
would have been a bizarre contrast to
the twisted Joker's of years past but
it's hard to get the ever-changing Joker
totally wrong it's the Joker's paradox
the more wrong you make him the better
he gets and that laughs is on point
though thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which Joker you
wish you could have seen